-Welcome back!
-Thanks. Thanks, buddy.
-Very exciting day for you
"The Irishman,"
a film that you were in,
nominated for an Academy Award
-10 of them.
-Yeah.
-Not bad.
-Pretty good, yeah.
-Not bad at all.
-Not bad, yeah.
We're very excited.
Yeah, it's an honor
to be in a movie like that
-And you also --
You and Rose Byrne
are in "Medea,"
which, your preview starte
last night.
How was that?
-It was good, you know?
It was sold out,
thousand people or so,
and they seemed to enjoy it.
They got up afterwards
and didn't leave.
-That's wonderful.
-So that was good, yeah.
And you know Rose
is extraordinary.
She's so good in it.
And I don't think
she's ever going to think
that it went well, but --
-Gotcha. So, now,
you and Rose, of course,
are partners in real life.
You have two children.
Is she that kind
of actor that --
-Well, she's just
tough on herself.
And, you know, the thing about
the theater, right, of course,
is, like, you do it,
and then it's gone forever
So you just -- You really
have to move on.
And I think it's a pretty
demanding role for her.
-Of course.
-And, you know,
I'm just going to get
to hear about it every night
-Well, it's interesting, 'caus
this is a very intense pla
about marriage
and relationships.
And you guys
are in a relationship.
-Tyler Perry comes in
in the middle of it.
-Now, see, now,
this is interesting.
Tyler Perry is not
in this "Medea."
-He's not in this.
-Right, okay, gotcha.
Do you feel as though
there's any sense that
you want to let the audience
know that ahead of time?
-Yeah, yeah. I bring it up every
now and then. Yeah, I'm like
I feel like we should have
Tyler Perry do the announcement.
-Like, you know,
like, "Unwrap the candies,
shut off your phone,
and I'm not in this."
-Right.
-And then give people
7 to 10 minutes to leave.
-Right, like, "We're going
to turn the lights off,
so you can leave if you want
It won't be shameful."
-Yeah.
-How -- You guys have
worked together before.
But again, this is very intense,
and it is about relationships.
Have you found it
harder or easier
to do it with somebody
that you share life with?
-You know what? The truth is
I'm a huge fan of Rose's.
And this is one
of the great roles
in the history of the theatre.
And there aren't that many great
roles, really, for women.
And so I was really very honored
to be asked to do it with her.
And I've got the best seat
in the house every night.
-That's fantastic.
-So, I'm thrilled
to do it with her.
-That's really exciting.
[ Applause ]
-You have a history,
a long history,
as a stage actor and film actor.
But you have also a histor
of hurting yourself onstage.
This is true?
-Oh, yeah.
Yeah, yeah. It's like
a contact sport for me.
Yeah, I've gotten hurt.
I've had more surgeries
from acting.
-Really?
-Yeah. You know --
-What were --
How do they happen?
-You know, like,
I'll do something
like I'll jump on a table.
And then -- Like, in rehearsal
And then I'll be like,
"Oh, yeah. I'm going to do tha
every night."
But your body doesn't know
you're acting.
Your body's like, "You're 49."
-Right, right.
-"Don't do that."
-And you're like,
"No, body, we're 32."
-Yeah, yeah. So after doing that
for two weeks,
my meniscus tears.
-Yeah.
-Or, you know,
I'm punching a wall every night,
and then, like,
I tear my rotator cuff.
So I got to fix that.
I walked into a metal pole
one night in the dark,
and I cut my face open.
I had four stitches in my face
you know.
-See, the first two
were kind of cool
'cause it was you being,
like, tough guy.
-Yeah, yeah.
I killed it with the last one.
-That's like when I -- You know,
I broke my wrist one time.
And I had this really grea
cast, you know, on my arm.
And people were like,
"What happened?"
And I had a Vespa at the time.
-Yeah.
-And I fell off my Vespa.
[ Laughter ]
But I stopped saying that
and I started saying
I fell off my bike,
'cause 20% of people thought
I meant motorcycle.
-Yeah.
-I figured.
-I mean this as a compliment
-Yeah.
-If you said bike to me, I would
think motorcycle before Vespa.
-Because I'm saying it.
You wouldn't think it was Vespa.
-Right, right, right, whereas,
if I say it,
I think people think,
like, Schwinn.
-Yeah, yeah.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, yeah. The same thin
with the meniscus.
-Yeah, exactly.
-It was jumping on a table
-Yeah, jumping on a table,
not the best way to do it.
-Yeah, yeah.
-You -- When you got your start,
your first head shot,
and I think a lot of us
in the acting game
have a first head shot
that we're maybe
a little embarrassed about
but you also filled your résum
with lies.
-Oh, yeah. Well, I didn't
have a lot of credits.
So I had a very large
special skills section.
-Yeah.
-So like half of the page was --
You know, you have to put
your credits down.
And then they want to know
like, what special skills
you have.
Multiple languages.
-Sure.
-So, I just -- I wrote
everything that I could do
-Right, just 'cause
you had to fill out the page
-Yeah, automobile driver.
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, right, stretch it out
-And then,
automobile driver/automatic.
Automobile driver/manual,
'cause it's longer than stick.
[ Laughter ]
Accents.
-Accents, right.
-I don't know any accents.
Horseback riding.
-And horseback riding came to --
-That one bit me in the ass.
-It did, yeah.
-Yeah, 'cause I had never
ridden a horse.
And then I got a job
where I had to ride a horse.
And Kevin Costner, director,
and he was the best.
He was the greatest.
And I remember, we got there
and it was rehearsal, thank God.
And they brought
the horse to me.
And I just looked at it.
[ Laughter ]
And he was like,
"You going to get on it?"
And I said, "Yeah, yeah.
I'm just -- Just waiting."
And he went, "You don't know
how to ride a horse."
So I went, "I don't know
how to ride --
I don't know
how to get on a horse."
And so he taught me
how to ride a horse.
-Really?
-Yeah, he was the best.
-And looking back,
when you look at that work
are you like, "That's
believable. I look like --
-No, 'cause I got completely
cut out of the movie.
-Did you really?
-Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, but I learned
how to ride a horse.
Kevin Costner was like --
-That's fantastic.
You got very --
Ultimately, you got paid
to take horseback riding lessons
from Kevin Costner.
-Pretty much, yeah, yeah.
There's no record of it at all
-No record of it at all.
You posted this photo
on your Instagram.
Is this from
your first communion?
Is that --
-Yeah.
How about that hairstyle?
-Everything about this --
-"No Country for Old Men."
-There's so much to unpack here.
Lookit. Yeah, it is.
-I had that hairstyle
before Javier Bardem.
-Yeah.
-This is a young Anton Chigurh
-That's right.
I had a big gap in my teet
before braces.
-Yeah. A very, very wide lapel
-The turned-down turtleneck.
Yeah, I think
I have a ring on, too.
It's on the other hand.
-Oh, it's on the other hand.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I have a little thing there.
-Do you look back now and go
"Gosh, it was like --"
The innocence that you wer
so happy in this photo,
not realizing the outfit
you were wearing?
-I thought I looked really good,
actually. I thought --
You should see
my first communion suit.
-Okay.
-'Cause that was inspired
by "Saturday Night Fever."
That was --
Not my first communion,
my confirmation suit.
-Oh, your first confirmation
-It was white and black.
-You also -- Is this swim team
-Yeah, you didn't have
to bring that out.
[ Laughter ]
-That's a very
confident swimmer.
Yeah.
-That pose is called
"The Package."
[ Laughter ]
-Bobby Cannavale, everybody.